the coping for our pool renovation project
just about ended me
and if I had known
I was gonna spend more than 20 hours
sitting on the hard concrete
working on it I might have reconsided
all of my life decisions
but ignorance as they say
is bliss and at this point I'm about
as ignorant as they come
so I got to work mixing up my mortar
and piping it in between my bricks
the aim of the game here
is to fix up some of the bricks
where the mortar is cracked or missing
and it was surprisingly a lot like
decorating a fluffy vanilla sponge
you know.. terrifying
after the mortar had set
It was time for me to try and make the bricks
look like anything other than what they currently look like
And I’ll tell ya
deciding on the best approach
to take with this coping
has been nothing short of
an absolute fkn nightmare
we had a bunch of spare bricks out back
so we tested out a lot of different ways
that we might be able to give this
a bit of a face lift
cause unfortunately
or fortunately
depending on how you look at it
the coping is here to stay
been told it's basically impossible to swap it out for anything
and one thing about me is I do love the
heritage that this home has
we settled on a lime wash paint
and while I got to work
starting that, Mark was painstakingly cutting
and shaping hundreds of tiles
I said it in the last part and I'll say it again
that spa has been a headache
on our test bricks
we also tried out a micro cement and also like a concrete paint
and I liked the finished look because these
bricks are pretty beat up
but it also made me quite worried
cause essentially it would just cover the bricks
and I kinda wanna make them work
but also most of my decisions are subject to change
so today I'm just testing this out and seeing I like it
Okay undercoats always look a bit like shit
so don't judge me but I think I like the
direction that this is heading in
I'm gonna quickly paint it again and crack on with the grouting
so I'm so sorry but you need to come
back for the update